Whether they're psychotic stalkers or pompous
jerks or just terrible decision-makers, significant
others in scary movies tend to cause a lot
more problems than they solve.
Let's take a look at the horror movie boyfriends
who were the absolute worst.
There's obsessed, and then there's David McCall.
In Fear, we're unfortunately introduced to
David, and he's any father's worst nightmare
right from the start.
It takes him almost no time to start developing
an unhealthy infatuation with our leading
lady, the teenaged Nicole, and bucking any
attempts by her dad to keep him away from
her.
Little by little, David starts to reveal how
unhinged and violent he is, harming everyone
from Nicole's best friend to a security guard
to the poor family dog.
Despite all that he does to her loved ones,
though, he still somehow believes that he
and Nicole have a future together.
Plus, he considers his lethal home invasion
plot to be a grand gesture that will lead
to a reunion.
He's dangerous and deranged and completely
clueless about what women want.
In other words: the full package.
The idea of a high school teacher engaging
in an affair with a student, even if the student
is past the age of consent, is upsetting under
any circumstance.
High school years are so formative and devoid
of responsible decision-making that it's inherently
dangerous and predatory for teachers to have
any personal relationship with students.
So, The Boy Next Door's Claire definitely
deserves some scorn for sleeping with Noah,
considering that he's her next-door neighbor,
her son's friend, and a student at her school.
But after she decides to call it quits as
a result of the guilt and shame she feels
about it all, his overreaction is intense.
Noah starts trying to win her back by vandalizing
the school wall with a lewd message about
their fling and blackmailing her with pictures
and a video of their tryst.
When that doesn't work, he starts making threats
to her family, and all of this comes with
the explicit caveat that his aggression will
only end if she continues being his girlfriend.
"No" definitely does not mean "no" for this
guy.
"So it's time to make a choice my love - you
either live with me or you die with them"
Technically, "Hugh," a.k.a. Jeff Redmond,
isn't a horror movie boyfriend, but he is
a horror movie hookup gone horribly wrong.
In It Follows, Hugh takes Jay out on a date,
first to the theater, and then to have a quick
drink.
Ultimately, he manages to convince Jay that
he's an ordinary guy with no ulterior motive,
and the two wind up hooking up in the back
of his car.
Once the deed is done, Hugh reveals the true
motive for his interest and advances.
He's passing on to her a terrifying supernatural
entity in the hopes that she'll then pass
it along to someone else, et cetera, until
Hugh is so far removed from the chain that
he can live a long, worry-free life.
The whole movie is a thinly-veiled metaphor
for the real-life threat of STDs, so Hugh's
decision to condemn Jay to a probable death
just to save his own skin is both indefensible
and one heck of a cinematic case for abstinence.
To be fair to Paranormal Activity's Micah,
he really did have a point when he said that
Katie should've given him some kind of heads
up about her family's ghost curse before she
moved in with him.
That still doesn't excuse some of the stupid
and unhelpful things he does once a vengeful
spirit begins wreaking havoc on their home.
For one thing, he has an annoyingly relentless
obsession with taping everything, but at least
that sets up a convenient plot device to help
frame the film in its signature found footage
style.
The real problem with Micah is that he decides
it's a grand idea to taunt the demon that
has been haunting them.
Then he ignores Katie's wishes by "borrowing"
a Ouija board, and of course all hell then
literally breaks loose.
It's one thing that he goes all Blair Witch
Project on everything, but it's quite another
when he starts actively inviting trouble from
the mad poltergeist .
"No, you haven't been having progress and
you’re not in control it is in control and
if you think you’re in control you’re
being an idiot.
Not a single thing you've done has helped."
Does a creepy internet stalker who pays a
girl to flirt actually qualify as a boyfriend?
The jury's still out on that one, but Tinker
is about as close as it gets in Cam.
He seems to genuinely care about Alice, calling
her directly on a regular basis to chit-chat
about her off-camera life and showering her
with tips and compliments.
He even moves to her hometown to try and win
her over in real life.
When the going gets tough, though, and Tinker
finds out that his favorite cam girl's feed
has been taken over by a computerized clone
version of her, he fails spectacularly to
intervene or even care very much.
Instead of helping Alice in her hour of need,
he sneaks off to chat with the impersonator
who is making her life so hellish, because
all he really cares about is looking at Alice
online, in any form.
It's bad enough that he takes the digital
adult entertainment game way too seriously,
but when he betrays Alice, that's when he
becomes truly disconnected.
From the beginning of Scream, it's clear that
there's something not quite right with Skeet
Ulrich's Billy Loomis.
With his shaggy hair, smouldering expressions,
and sense of entitlement, he doesn't do much
to hide the fact that he's a generic dirtbag
throughout the whole movie.
What we don't find out until the end, though,
is just how thoroughly depraved he really
is.
After successfully luring Sidney to give up
her virginity to him, Billy's free to then
let his partner-in-crime Stu take her out
now.
It doesn't work, and she eventually finds
out that the two of them are responsible for
all of those phone calls and cat-and-mouse
games.
Billy and Stu say it's all just revenge for
Sidney's mother breaking up the Loomis parents'
marriage and that they're just emulating scary
movies with their approach.
Still, there's something particularly sinister
to Billy turning his relationship with Sidney
into a bedroom conquest that must be completed
before the killing can begin.
On top of being a psycho killer, he's also
a sleaze.
"What's the matter, Sidney?
You look like you’ve seen a ghost.
Why are you doing this?
It’s all part of the game Sydney.
"It's called 'Guess How I'm Gonna Die!'"
There's no doubt that the most abusive relationship
Sarah has in The Craft is with Nancy and the
pair of selfish sidekicks who enable her.
However, Ulrich's Chris Hooker is a classic
case of creepy as well.
Instead of trying to pursue a legitimate relationship
with Sarah, he decides to go and sully her
reputation before she's even had a chance
to establish one at her new school.
He does this by telling everyone that he's
already slept with her just to make himself
look all big and bro-tastic.
Chris is eventually put under a love spell
by Nancy's coven, so he might not be to blame
for every single one of his acts of desperation.
But the curse probably only elevates behaviors
that he is already capable of.
So when he later tries to force himself on
Sarah after she refuses to sleep with him,
that is certainly still him being an inappropriate
scumbag, cursed or not.
Carter Duncan might be what the title's referring
to in The Perfect Guy, but he is anything
but.
At first, he seems completely handsome and
charming and exactly what Leah needs to get
over her breakup with her ex-boyfriend Dave.
But when a simple encounter at a gas station
with a stranger turns into a full-on attack
from her new lover, his true personality reveals
itself.
He's not warm at all; instead, he's vicious
and impetuous and dangerous.
Breaking up is hard to do under even the best
of circumstances, but when a guy has as many
screws loose as Carter, it's practically impossible.
Leah ends up having to recruit her ex to protect
her from Carter as he stalks her at work,
sneaks into her home, and even steals her
cat.
And that's the tame stuff.
Eventually, things turn violent, and Leah
must take matters into her own hands to prevent
him from doing this all again, to her or other
unsuspecting women.
If you thought your last Tinder date was terrible,
this guy could make anyone look like "swipe
right" potential by comparison.
It's hard to know what possessed Jenna to
ever date Trent in the first place in the
Friday the 13th reboot.
But a lot of slasher movies don't exactly
work if the characters actually use logic
and make good choices.
Trent is spoiled and arrogant and only invites
his "friends" to his parents' lake house to
show off how wealthy he and his family are.
Trent is also completely unkind.
He even starts an argument with a guy who
is only out searching for his missing sister.
On top of all those terrible personality traits,
he's also a cheater of the worst order.
As soon as Jenna steps away from the lake
house to do a good deed, he hooks up with
her best friend, and their love scene is cringey
enough to make anyone wonder why Jenna gives
him the time of day.
What he says about female anatomy will make
you laugh and cry all at once.
Beauty is only skin deep with this one, that's
for sure.
To be fair to The Fly's Seth Brundle, it isn't
necessarily his fault that he's being slowly
morphed into the Brundlefly.
But that doesn't mean anyone would want to
put up with him once the side effects start
kicking in.
Even before he merges DNA with a horsefly,
Seth is a bit questionable as boyfriend material.
Not only is he odd, he's also a bit possessive
of his journalist girlfriend, Ronnie.
But Seth becomes most unpleasant after his
little teleportation experiment goes so wrong.
He becomes aggressive and eventually loses
all trace of empathy and emotion.
Instead of protecting Ronnie from the danger
he poses to her, he tries to force her to
carry his baby to term and even attempts to
fuse all three of them together into one entity.
It's bad enough that he gets himself into
this mess by being so sloppy with his work
station.
But the fact that he wants to drag his girlfriend
and unborn child down with him makes Seth
an especially buggin' boyfriend.
What's a guy to do do when the woman he loves
is suddenly turned into a Deadite by an ancient
evil force that's been awoken by a weird book?
For Ash Williams in The Evil Dead, the answer
is to decapitate Linda and then slice her
still-animated body into bits.
What a catch.
Never mind the fact that this is all his fault,
as he's the one who brought out the Necronomicon
and tape reading that set all the hellfire
in motion in the first place.
Even if we forgive that, it's his next action
that proves he's completely undateable forever.
The 2000 video game Evil Dead: Hail to the
King continues the Ash action and shows him
dating a poor girl named Jenny, whom he convinces
to go to the same cabin where all of the crazy
and terrible things happened before.
We're later told she died in an "accident"
with a bus, but that's a little too convenient
to be true, isn't it?
Any time a guy has an alter-ego called "Bad
Ash," it ain't good news.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.